[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln
der presseclub
herzlich willkommen zum presseclub an
diesem sonntag schön dass sie dabei sind
schön dass wir unsere runde hier
begleiten wollen china übt nach eigenen
angaben den ernstfall nämlich die
eroberung taiwans das sei zwar nur eine
militärübung aber wir haben ja in diesem
jahr schon erlebt wie schnell daraus
ernst werden kann beim russischen
angriff auf die ukraine man muss dazu
sagen der konflikt um taiwan droht schon
länger außer kontrolle zu geraten
und trotzdem oder vielleicht auch
deshalb ist nancy pelosi in dieser woche
nach taiwan gereist sie ist die
vorsitzende des us repräsentantenhauses
und damit die ranghöchste us politikerin
sie seit 25 jahren auf die insel
gekommen ist die folge die spannungen
zwischen den usa und china haben sich
verschärft
diese drohgebärden haben eine neue
dimension
china demonstriert mit militärmanövern
gegenüber taiwan stärke den vorwand für
das säbelrasseln liefert ihr auftritt in
nancy pelosi zeigt sich auf ihre
asienreise mit taiwan solidarisch
sie können versuchen teil waren davon
abzuhalten andere orte zu besuchen aber
sie werden teil waren nicht isolieren
indem sie uns daran hindern dorthin zu
reisen
china sieht das als provokation
zum hintergrund nach dem ende des
bürgerkriegs 1949 ruft bauer die
volksrepublik aus die unterlegenen
nationalisten ziehen sich auf die insel
taiwan zurück das autokratische china
wächst so großmacht heran keine 200
kilometer entfernt wird taiwan zu einer
eigenständigen demokratie
diplomatische beziehungen unterhalten
die meisten länder jedoch vor allem zur
volksrepublik
außenministerium wer bock zieht
angesichts einer sich verschärfenden
krise aber eine klare linie wir
akzeptieren nicht wenn das
internationale recht gebrochen wird oder
ein größerer nachbar völkerrechtswidrig
sein kleineren nachbarn über feld und
das gilt natürlich auch für china gerade
in diesen tagen deutschland hat wichtige
handelsbeziehungen zu beiden ländern der
konflikt könnte auch unsere wirtschaft
empfindlich treffen und was wenn aus
militärmanövern plötzlich bitterer ernst
wird china gegen die usa das wäre eine
eskalation von globalem ausmaß
militär vor taiwan china lässt die
muskeln spielen das ist unser thema
heute hier im presseclub ich freue mich
auf meine gäste und sage schon mal
herzlich willkommen erics baum er ist
freier journalist in berlin unter
anderem für die amerikanische los
angeles times und die south china
morning post in hongkong herzlich
willkommen sage ich auch susanne koelbl
heute bei uns sie ist auslandes
reporterin für das magazin der spiegel
auch in der runde herzlich willkommen
ist felix lee bis 2019 china
korrespondent in peking für die taz die
tageszeitung im moment in berlin für die
zeitung vor allem mit dem thema
weltwirtschaft beschäftigt und die runde
komplett macht daniela er war bis vor
kurzem china korrespondent der ard es
seit einem monat zurück aus peking und
redakteur beim norddeutschen rundfunk
schon dass sie in der runde sind alle
zusammen und mit mir dieses thema
besprechen wollen und sie sind natürlich
auch sehr gerne dabei sie wissen dass
der pressegruppe wird live gestreamt in
den sozialen medien beteiligen sie sich
der gerne mit kommentaren und natürlich
auch mit fragen wir versuchen das dann
hier gerne mit in die sendung
einzupacken ja nancy pelosi war kaum
abgereist da war sofort zu spüren was
dieser besuch ausgelöst hat große
chinesische militär manöver vor der
küste taiwans es gab die übungen für sie
für luft blockaden raketen wurden
abgeschossen es gab sofort sanktionen
für taiwanische unternehmen im
lebensmittelbereich zum beispiel
außerdem wurden gespräche zwischen china
und den usa ausgesetzt unter anderem zu
den themen klima und verteidigung und
nancy pelosi selbst wurde auch mit
sanktionen belegt genauso wie ihre
engsten angehörigen
all das also schon mal so ein kleiner
abriss nur aus dieser woche helly war es
die reise wert wenn wir uns das
anschauen
das muss ich muss ich jetzt in den
nächsten tagen und wochen monaten auch
noch mal muss man das genaue beobachten
ich halte den besuch generell für
wichtig also ich grundsätzlich ist
sondern müssen besucher politische
besucher zwischen ländern der freien
welt möglich sein und taiwan ist teil
der freien welt also dass grundsätzlich
über den zeitpunkt kann man sich
strategisch sicherlich streiten aber
dann stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage wann ist denn der richtige
zeitpunkt also ich möchte nochmals
betonen wir haben erst vor zwei jahren
die niederschlagung der
demokratiebewegung in hongkong
china hat die den zeitpunkt genutzt der
rest der welt mit der pandemie
beschäftigt war und hat mit einem
sicherheitsgesetz quasi sämtliche
freiheitsrechte in hongkong quasi
aufgehoben und den autonomie den
völkerrechtlich
autonomiestatus aufgehoben und die
westliche welt hat gar nicht reagiert
oder viel zu spät reagiert also insofern
muss man sagen dass die usa immerhin
jetzt den mumm hat da jetzt auch mal
zeichen zu setzen vor allem frau pelosi
und insofern auch zu zeigen china kann
nicht machen was es was es will sondern
da gibt es auch noch andere kräfte die
das versuchen auch einzudämmen also
insofern finde es nur gut und richtig
dass frau pelosi da war ein zeichen
gesetzt teilen sie die meinung von
körper oder hätte man auf die drohungen
und warnungen diese im vorhinein gab
auch so reagieren können dass man sagt
also wenn sie bloß dass diese reise
spare ich mir zu diesem zeitpunkt der
zeitpunkt ist wahrscheinlich günstig für
frau per los sie im ersten in erster
hinsicht nämlich weil sie bald selbst
möglicherweise nicht mehr wiedergewählt
wird und dass die letzte möglichkeit für
sie gewesen sein könnte
überhaupt so eine reise zu machen in
dieser position
grundsätzlich teile ich die auffassung
dass man
dieses statement machen muss so verband
zu stehen die den zeitpunkt halte ich
deswegen für nicht günstig weil das ist
ja ein größeres konzert wir haben eine
neue lage in der hinsicht dass sich
plötzlich
wir haben das im ukraine krieg gesehen
dass die positionierungen deutlich sein
müssen ein durch die westliche welt oder
die freie welt muss miete muss
miteinander abgestimmt handeln frau
pelosi hat jetzt eigentlich nicht getan
sondern sie hat sie ist hingefahren zu
einem zeitpunkt wo ihr eigener präsident
sagt das halte ich jetzt nicht für ihn
günstigen moment wo das militär auch
gesagt wir wollen jetzt eigentlich diese
reaktionen nicht unbedingt im raum
stehen haben die wir die wir nicht
kontrollieren können man muss in dem
zusammenhang sehen beiden hat mit seiner
regierung im moment versucht diesen
ganzen raum
eher diskret
zusammenzuführen also er war im mai in
der region er spricht sie versuchen mit
denen sie haben sie haben das neue
bündnis mit australien opfers es gibt
viele tätigkeiten um genau diese diesen
freien länder die uns viel näher stehen
zusammenzuführen und ein starkes bündnis
zu bauen dass china eintreten soll ganz
kurze frage hätte beiden oder hätte
irgendwann in den usa die chance gehabt
nancy pelosi daran zu hindern diese
reise zu machen das ist eben das problem
oder das missverständnis im ausland dass
der präsident eigentlich nicht so viel
macht hat und beiden als lange senator
weiß dass nancy pelosi machen kann was
sie will das ist ein unabhängiger
verfassungsorgan der kongress oder nancy
pelosi
da hinweisen will der präsident kann
kaum sagen eine skination das versteht
vielleicht china nicht als deutsche
nicht aber der kongress vorsitzende ist
eine sehr mächtige person aber sie haben
recht die politik wirkt vielleicht nicht
mehr lange vorsitzende der
repräsentantenhaus die demokraten will
november vielleicht die macht und sie
wird dann nicht mehr und von nancy
pelosi war es jetzt oder nie eigentlich
wenn sie jetzt nicht das macht gibt es
vielleicht die chancen nicht mehr und
als die politik wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass seit über 30 jahren eine
starke verfechter von menschenrechten
starke gegner von china seit 1990 ein
plakat ausgerollt und tina maze square
als sie es wirklich leben lang diese
menschenrecht thema gewidmet und sie
wollte ein zeichen setzen ein bisschen
wie charles kennedy mark west berlin
gereist ist und 63 und sagte ich bin ein
berliner nancy pelosi wurde die
warnsignale sind wir stehen bei euch wie
für die demokratie die freiheit in
taiwan ist wahnsinnig wichtig und wir
stehen dazu wir müssen härter hat das
vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen
einordnen weil es gibt ja natürlich noch
viele menschen die sich daran erinnern
es gab auch schon mal einen hochrangigen
besuch nehmen sich 1997 der us
parlamentspräsident ist damals nach
teheran gereist da gab es vorher auch
sehr viel kritik aber danach nicht diese
reaktion warum nicht was hat sich
verändert
1997 war china natürlich ein ganz
anderes land und gar nicht dieser
weltpolitische player diese angehende
aufstrebende großmacht und schon
garnicht
zweitgrößte wirtschaftsmacht dieses
planet das militär war bei weitem nicht
so aufgebaut wie es jetzt ist und der
damalige kp von staatschef jiang zemin
hatte vor allem einen fokus damals 1997
nämlich die sozusagen saubere rückholung
der britischen kronkolonie hongkong
zurück an die volksrepublik die übergabe
stand für den sommer bevor und davor war
eben der besuch von newt gingrich
geplant und man hat jetzt im nachhinein
gehört dass es da schon verhandlungen
gab das war den natürlich auch ein dorn
im auge dass der überlegte nach taipeh
nach taiwan zu fliegen aber
am ende hat man sich wohl darauf
geeinigt er kommt erst in peking vorbei
ist dann in shanghai auch noch in der
volksrepublik und fliegt dann nicht
direkt nach taiwan sondern erst mal nach
tokio macht sozusagen diesen
diplomatischen
ausfallschritt um den chinesische und
welche diesen staatsführung gerecht zu
werden und schlägt in taiwan auf aber
china war damals nicht das was es heute
ist und die taiwan vielleicht auch nicht
muss man das auch sagen dass sich ja
auch die position taiwans für alle die
dort interessen haben geändert hat herr
liebt warum ist eigentlich taiwan so
wichtig für china naja taiwan waren 90
tatsächlich auch schon eine demokratie
insofern opfer aus us sicht auch schon
ein wichtiger faktor heute hat taiwan
aber nochmal eine besondere rolle und
zwar aus wirtschaftlicher sicht also
taiwan ist quasi monopolist bei den ganz
hoch entwickelten mikrochips also den
halbleitern 90 prozent die weltweit für
seite von iphones über elektrogeräte bis
hin zu waffensystem benötigt werden
kommen aus taiwan also dass wir auch
gleich auf jeden fall nochmal darüber
sprechen welche gesamte
weltwirtschaftliche bedeutung dass dann
auch für mögliche entscheidungen haben
wird auf jeden fall aber natürlich es
geht auch um die straße von taiwan an
der meerenge zwischen taiwan und china
da geht fast die hälfte des weltweiten
handels gibt durch diese meerenge und
das ist natürlich auch
aufs us sich natürlich ein wichtiger
faktor aussicht japan südkorea alles
große wichtige volkswirtschaften und
china natürlich auch da die kontrolle zu
haben oder beziehungsweise wenn eins
dieser oder wenn china die kontrolle
allein über diese meerenge hat dann
fühlen sich natürlich andere länder da
auch bedroht zumal ich glaube was
hast du den militärschlag beträgt ich
rechne ja gar nicht mal so sehr dass in
unmittelbarer
eine unmittelbare gefahr eines
militärschlags china gegenteil war
geschehen wird sondern es reicht ja
völlig aus wenn china die diese
handelswege blockiert dann wäre die
gesamte welt schon betroffen wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass frau koelbl das
wirklich aus diesen übungen ja aktuell
die als wenn man es realistisch
betrachtet ja auch schon eine blockade
sind also in dieser woche mussten ja
auch schon schiffe einen bogen machen
zum teil
tag verzögerung dadurch das ist ja alles
noch überschaubar aber für
wahrscheinlich halten sie es dass diese
blockaden die wir jetzt erleben auch ja
zur realität werden ich halte die im
moment für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
ist dass das unglück dabei ist es dass
sie sozusagen in realität üben konnten
sie wissen sie wissen jetzt wie es geht
sie wissen wie sie es machen können sie
wissen was sie brauchen und was sie
vielleicht mehr dazu benötigen und sie
kennen auch ungefähr die reaktion die
darauf folgen könnten das ist ein
wettbewerbsnachteil eben in diesem in
diesem geschäft ich möchte aber noch mal
darauf zurückkommen gerade gerade weil
hier das
oder weil insgesamt das so positiv
aufgenommen wird es ist positiv sich
sich loyal zu taiwan und zu dieser
demokratie zu stellen aber wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel wenn man sich jetzt
einfach mal die landkarte anguckt da ist
japan hat sie auch besucht südkorea die
waren teilweise überhaupt nicht
glücklich darüber weil die müssen das
nehme ich aushalten die müssen nämlich
in dieser nachbarschaft leben und die
müssen das sehr genau austarieren wie
sie mit china australien ganz genau so
die wollen mit china nicht verfallen
wird sein gleichzeitig schließen sie in
der allianz die die er die eben westlich
orientiert ist das ist eine ganz
sensible angelegenheit und das muss
abgestimmt sein das muss diplomatisch
abgestimmt sein und da habe ich
bitteschön irgendwie also da vielstimmig
zu sprechen ist einfach eine große
gefahr und wenn das nicht abgestimmt
wird dann früh verfrühstücken die
chinesen diese länder einzeln und das
ist genau das was eben nicht sein so wir
haben jetzt liter und liter und was
glaube ich die die so eine art
dependance von von thailand der eltern
von taiwan eröffnet haben und plötzlich
alle verträge werden in frage gestellt
schweden
beschwert sich über bestimmte über
bestimmte arbeitsverhältnisse und was
ich was weil die uiguren wirklich
herausfinden dass sie und uhren da
zwangsarbeit gleich aber sie sprechen
eine spannende sache an nämlich wie man
sich auch weltwirtschaftlich und so
weiter aufstellen muss um als reaktion
auf das was da gerade passiert welche
frau würde ich spreche vor allem davon
dass man einigkeit und abgesprochen hier
vorgehen muss ansonsten ist der gegner
den man hier vor sich hat eigentlich
nicht zu bewältigen es ist es ist ein
sehr kompliziertes diplomatisches feld
und da kann man nicht alleine malen eine
performance hinlegen wir werden gleich
auf jeden fall noch ich würde ganz gerne
noch einmal kurz bei der wahl bleiben
bevor wir auch genau in diesem bereich
rein gehen nämlich wie man politisch
reagieren sollte auch mit
wirtschaftlichen einschränkungen
vielleicht hertha wir reden aber ich
zumindest das gefühl alles viel zu wenig
auch über die taiwaner und hernerinnen
wie einem die listen erlebt sagen die
jetzt toll dass nancy pelosi da war und
und unser problem unsere bedrohungslage
in den fokus gerückt ist oder erleben
sie die frau auch gerade angesprochen
hat er so also das ist jetzt auch eine
deutliche verschlechterung unserer
situation
naja die deutliche verschlechterung
ihrer situation haben glaube ich viele
menschen in taiwan beobachten können als
wir im jahr 2019 drei jahre ist es her
die große protestbewegung in hongkong
gesehen haben und dann vor allem infolge
dieser proteste da ging es ja den leuten
darum dass ein von peking geplantes
auslieferungsabkommen man konnte also so
war der plan in hongkong inhaftiert
werden und dann an festlandchina
ausgeliefert werden dass das unterbunden
werden sollte das hat 100.000 millionen
menschen auf die straße gebracht weil
sie gesagt haben das unterminiert die
völkerrechtlich garantierten freiheiten
die uns peking zugesagt hat unter diesem
1 1 starts wahlsysteme
verabredung mit mit den mit den
internationalen partnern mit
großbritannien und wie uns werden hier
die freiheitsrechte bestrebt
abgeschnitten so und und was passierte
in folge dessen es wurde 2020 ein jahr
nach diesem großen protesten sozusagen
tabula rasa gemacht und peking hat mit
dem sogenannten nationale
sicherheitsgesetz felix lee hat es eben
auch schon mal zitiert klar gemacht eure
pressefreiheit meinungsfreiheit
versammlungsfreiheit eure demokratischen
grundrechte wir bisher hier genossen
habe sind weg die menschen in taiwan
haben das sehr genau gesehen und wir
haben in der zeit auch beobachten können
dass es so ein sohn so eine bewegung gab
von leuten die gesagt haben taiwan und
wir müssen friedlich koexistieren nicht
nur wirtschaftlich sondern auch
sozusagen politisch angenähert ans
festland seien und dass es da eine
bewegung hin gehabt zu dem wir müssen
uns vielleicht doch überlegen was wir
mit diesem festlandchina mit der
kommunistischen führung und ihren
ambitionen machen vor dem hintergrund
was sie gerade in hongkong passiert und
laatzen die bewegung gegeben wir haben
gerade schon japan handy angedeutet
gekommen waren ist überhaupt damit zu
rechnen dass china da vielleicht
tatsächlich diese eroberung in die
realität umsetzt aber hacker sprach mich
würde interessieren und das treibt auch
unsere user rum jetzt hier gibt es zum
beispiel die frage würde die eu taiwan
im ernstfall bei stehen für sie erst mal
vielleicht auch die frage würden die usa
denn tatsächlich an die seite treten von
taiwan wenn dieser ernstfall eintreten
will dann ist es so die waage frage die
videos frage strittige ständiges aber
beiden hat jetzt drei mal in diesem jahr
gesagt wir werden taiwan militärisch
unterstützen insofern beiden hat
anscheinend neue politik chinas
signalisieren wohnen wir werden teil
militärisch unterstützen und in hinblick
auf ukraine ja man sieht was passiert
wenn man zu lang als audio zu lange rede
zu lange kompromiss sucht mit muss man
dann gibt es der angriff und in den usa
ist mehr und mehr das gedanke man muss
wirklich klaren hier gegen china jetzt
zeigen und signalisieren klar im umfeld
es wird ein hoher preis geben wenn er
angreift und die usa unterstützt high
line jetzt mit waffen dieser art stachus
scheinpolitik dass es wird sehr sehr
schwierig sein für china sehr hohe
kosten geben und das ist auch in chinas
interesse einen krieg so haben china hat
eine florierende wirtschaft morgen wohnt
das kaputt aber interessant dass sie
sagen wir auch da gibt es eine frage
dazu kann sich in einen krieg eigentlich
leisten wenn man das jetzt mal so zu
ende denkt ali ist das realistisch also
wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn überhaupt
dass china sich darauf einlassen würde
na ja ich würde zumindest
ideen ping ist nicht putin also
hinter den pink steht schon eine
kollektiv führung autoritär aber
kollektiv und da gibt es natürlich auch
unterschiedliche interessen und vor
allem hat die chinesische führung ganz
starke wirtschaftliche interessen
da ist man sich bei puttinger inzwischen
nicht mehr so sicher wie viel gewicht
dass überhaupt noch hat in china hat das
sehr viel gewicht das insofern stimme
ich zu also glaube ich auch aus china
hat kein interesse an einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung aber
jean ping hat schon ganz klar das ziel
auch in seiner amtszeit treibern
zurückzuholen zurückzuholen finde ich
auch immer muss man der
anführungsstrichen ziehen weil ich
glaube taiwan thailand ist die teil der
volksrepublik gewesen sondern als taiwan
quasi als 1 1 eigenes souveräner staat
entstand weil die volksrepublik noch
nicht ausgerufen also insofern ist da
auch
ist auch da in der sie in der
interpretation lassen sich auch gleich
gerne darüber reden wie die
installierung selber nichtsdestotrotz
ich glaube schon also einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung ist
china jetzt nicht interessiert aber und
dann glaube ich da gibt es schon noch
viele mittel als es würde ausreichen
wenn china die handelswege blockiert die
für die alle beteiligten länder aber
auch insbesondere aber natürlich
existenziell sind und dass dazu dienten
diese aktuellen man war ja auch einfach
mal zu testen wie so eine
handelsblockade denn mal aussehen oder
schadet schiene auch was china davon ja
aber der schaden ist natürlich für so
eine große ohne große volkswirtschaft
für china weit aus dem verhältnis
geringer als es für sie doch eine
verhältnismäßig kleine volkswirtschaft
für taiwan ist aber es ist natürlich
auch ein test gewesen und insofern würde
ich in kolding der hinsicht auch ein
bisschen widersprechen also frau pelosi
jetzt besucht hat ja nicht die bedrohung
durch china überhaupt erst ausgelöst die
gab es ja die ganze zeit schon gegeben
ich würde sogar sagen china hat den
pelosi besucher bewusst aufgeputscht es
hat ja vorher auch schon politiker
besuch aus westlichen ländern gegeben um
genau auch mal zu testen wie weit würde
teil angehen wie weit würde der westen
gegen wie weit würden die usa gehen wie
weit würden auch die europäer gehen wie
die reagieren und das wollte man jetzt
alles mal anhand dieses mal was anhand
dieses besuches mal sehen und deswegen
was die konsequenzen und das werden wir
wahrscheinlich dass in den nächsten
wochen und monaten also nach meinem nach
malé sad geht es da wirklich ums
protokoll also wie wir wissen das und
andere leute dorthin gefahren sind es
hat überhaupt keinen aufbruch weiß gar
nichts in der zeitung groß stand ja
heute heute sagte irgendwie ich habe
mich schon gegen china gewendet und was
ich was mich da stark gemacht als es
noch nicht populär und
so so so so viel wind gemacht hat und so
aber in wahrheit ist es doch so dass ist
die nummer drei das ist ein
monolithischer apparat
vergleichsweise in china und wird nicht
wirklich verstanden als etwas was ich
glaube nicht dass man in wekeln wirklich
versteht dass es möglich und denkbar ist
dass das militär und der präsident nicht
in abstimmung handeln
mit der mit der
mit der sprecherin des des haares dort
eineinhalb stunden lang mit jean ping
gesprochen hat ihm sichtlich frage mag
das polo sie mag das unabhängig von
wasser sagt beiden war dagegen das weist
china auch ja ja aber es ist ein
wirklich glaubwürdig dass er würde gerne
sagen einem piloten da wenn du dich
einverstanden dass präsident dann ist
das nicht so schlimm also ich glaube
nicht dass die wirklich sagen ich glaube
nicht dass sie wirklich sagen na dann
kein problem zum beispiel gibt es diese
vereinbarung in europa das die ersten
fünf also die top five und die top sie
also deutschland zum beispiel topfen und
in europa die tops würden nicht fahren
ich glaube es ist umgekehrt in
deutschland die top 7 nicht fahren und
die in europa die top five nicht haben
das ist nicht das ist eine
protokollarische angelegenheit das heißt
also abgeordnete sind okay und alles was
höher es ist problematisch da werden wir
auch darüber reden weil es natürlich
auch um reaktionen aus deutschland gehen
muss in dieser situation ist gab er
einige schon zu hören in dieser woche
ich würde ganz gerne noch einen gedanken
in die runde geben weil wir gerade über
die blockaden gesprochen haben den
status den taiwan hat auch in der
halbleiterindustrie ist das auch eine
art lebensversicherung für taiwan dass
man sah so gut aufgestellt ist wäre das
interesse der westlichen welt man muss
ja auch mal dazu sagen sowohl usa als
auch china als auch die eu und
deutschland alle hängen da an dieser
produktion auch dran ist das nat
lebensversicherung für taiwan es kommt
auf jeden fall das hat sich erst
kürzlich entwickelt dass sie diese diese
fünf nanometer chips produzieren und
also führend sind ist es auf jeden fall
etwas was dass sie viel unabhängig
gemacht ich glaube aber dass durch die
ukraine krieg ich das eigentlich in
hongkong also meinetwegen auch durch
bloßes reise das war das sind alles
backup chaos wo jetzt ganz klar ist
diese demokratien müssen verteidigt
werden ansonsten sind sie verloren und
das ist genau das was im moment
geschieht und es kommt ein ganz vitalis
ganz massives interesse daran in
deutschland zum beispiel ist ja sehr
stark abhängig von der autoindustrie ich
glaube 250.000 milliarden
im wert von 52 milliarden verkauften sie
sogar die autos nach china auf jeden
fall sind dort unglaubliche werte um die
es in der deutschen wirtschaft geht und
die hängen ganz eng zusammen genau mit
solchen halbleitern hertha sie nicken
ist sehen sie das so dass taiwan auch
vor allem deshalb überhaupt diese
aufmerksamkeit bekommt ja und auch weil
weil sozusagen jetzt einmal der mediale
fokus drauf gelegt ist das ist sozusagen
für mich was ich schätze an dem an dem
pelosi trip oder in der analyse was hat
das bewirkt viele menschen hier in
deutschland haben sich plötzlich mit
taiwan überhaupt auseinander gesetzt und
haben mal angefangen sich darüber
gedanken zu machen was ist das überhaupt
für ein konstrukt völkerrechtlich wie
sie wieder aufgestellt warum haben wir
mit denen hier was zu tun die wir hängen
wie wirtschaftlich mit denen zusammen
und können sich jetzt auch eine
politische meinung bilden zu der frage
muss denn die bundesregierung mehr
mehr auf den tisch hauen müssen die
sozusagen auch sich überlegen ob
nicht nur abgeordnete ob nicht nur
parlamentarier
ob nicht nur leute aus dem kreise der eu
hin reisen ist das eine aber sich auch
zu wort melden insofern jetzt wieder mit
chinesischer brille der kommunistischen
führung das sind auf jeden fall immer
bereiche diddy
diddy richtig hassen und nicht mögen
dass das zwick die richtig im fell und
die müssen sich jedes mal überlegen wie
sie mit diesen irritationen umgehen
müssen wir haben jetzt ja gesehen dass
wurde eine riesenwelle veranstaltet im
vorfeld hätte man es auch leider das ist
das ist diesen besuch ich auch die
chinesen auch die chinesische führung
hat es durchaus leiser durchaus
selbstbewusster und mit durchaus mehr
teflon machen können aber sie haben es
für ihre zwecke genutzt
sie haben ein militärmanöver vom stapel
laufen lassen was jetzt als testlabor
gut für sie funktioniert und klar glaube
ich auch dass keating und der innere
zirkel in joomla im regierungs distrikt
pekings von ganz vielen innenpolitischen
baustellen ablenkt das kommt jetzt auch
sehr schön passend dass man das selber
kurzzeit guck mal wir haben tolles stars
wie in krise gerade dort wir haben die
situation dass ich ihn wegen ja im
herbst seine dritte amtszeit antreten
will also für ihn ist es auch so ein
bisschen wie wir es gerade angesprochen
haben bei nancy pelosi jetzt oder nie
ist ein ganz guter zeitpunkt auch dass
ich vielleicht noch mal neu zu
positionieren ich würde gerne noch mal
den blick so ein bisschen auf die
situation wie geht es jetzt weiter
richten also wie kann man reagieren ich
meine es ist nicht davon auszugehen dass
ist jetzt mit sonntag strich drunter
militärmanöver abgeschlossen wir müssen
uns nicht mehr darum kümmern maria hat
zum beispiel über youtube gefragt würde
sich deutschland bei entsprechenden
reaktionen chinas denn auch auf taiwans
seite stellen das ist natürlich jetzt
auch eine große frage die kann man
wirtschaftlich beantworten aber auch
politisch ich würde gerne politisch
damals dabei bleiben deutschland oder
zumindest die deutsche außenministerin
hat sich an dieser woche schon
überraschend deutlich positioniert frau
koelbl der richtige weg da so eine
position einzunehmen und zu sagen wir
haben gerade auch noch mal gehört im
beitrag der große nachbar darf den
kleinen nicht angreifen also ich glaube
dass deutschland sich quasi schon sie
haben sich positioniert das heißt was
bedeutet das also man muss auch dazu
sagen so richtig einheitlich
positioniert sich deutschland auch nicht
mehr da kommen wir vielleicht auch
gleich noch mal drauf die
außenministerin hat sich positioniert
und nach dem beispiel ukraine und nach
dem beispiel hongkong glaube ich dass es
eher konsens ist als nicht konsens ist
und was bedeutet dass das ist die frage
in jedem fall bedeutet es eine engere
partnerschaft mit den usa die ja
teilweise irgendwie auch in frage
gestellt war nach wir kriegen irak die
nato fragte sich wo ist eigentlich unser
gemeinsames ziel wo ist unser
gemeinsames
verteidigungs
wo ist unser gemeinsamer verteidigungs
raum ich glaube da kommt jetzt
inzwischen sehr viel mehr klarheit
hinein es ist so dass
china als als als bedrohung wahrgenommen
wird
es gibt europäische europäische länder
die angegriffen werden kritisiert werden
sanktioniert werden das kann man nur
gemeinsam bewältigen insofern und die
ukraine hat eindeutig gezeigt dass eine
frühzeitige bewaffnung eine frühzeitige
klärung in welchem bündnis und so lang
steht das angegriffen wird und welche
mit welcher unterstützung rechnen kann
und ich glaube hier gibt es zum beispiel
auch ganz empfindlichen bereichen
militär da ist jetzt nicht deutschland
unbedingt führen dabei es geht um diese
um diese hyperschall waffen die china
und russland zum beispiel haben die
amerikaner entwickeln sie gerade und
dauert wohl noch ein zwei jahre bis sie
völlig einzusetzen sind dafür muss
wiederum einen abwehrschirm dies gilt
diese linien klar zu ziehen da verstehe
ich sie richtig das ist das was jetzt
auf jeden fall deutlich passieren sollte
das passiert alles um das passiert und
es gibt ja auch in den usa reaktionen
auf das wie sich deutschland aufstellt
ist das im sinne der amerikaner wie zb
eben sicher auch klar jetzt die
außenministerin positioniert da ich
glaube die usa würde es begrüßen in
deutschland mehr position wir über ganz
deutlich sagen würden wie die subtilen
stehen deutschland hat eine große nase
bedient hier mit dieser politik wandel
der handel und wandel es hat nicht
geklappt mit muss man das klappt nicht
mit mit china beiden amerikanische
präsidenten samt und seide haben lange
geweint dass schiene ist die größte
bedrohung deutschland hat fröhlich
weiterhin einfach geschäfte gemacht mit
china es war eine umfrage vor ein zwei
jahren das fast so viele deutsche haben
eine positive
meinung zu china aus usa 34 37 war
erstaunt wie positiv muss
auch ein bisschen geändert wieder in
einem halben jahr die umfrage jetzt
machen würde wäre es spiele anderes
schwankten natürlich aber räumlich noch
nicht was die amerikaner wenn die wollen
dass china seine gefahr die austria die
haben wir haben sich gewandt und die
haben jetzt gute gekauft und ich sehen
die gefahr von china und deutschland ich
mein freund deutschland ich war ja
studenten aus in berlin und man könnte
die freiheit in berlin sehen aus
vergleich zu der ddr es war ein
wahnsinns beispiel es gibt es gleich in
taiwan und china jetzt mal würde trägen
ein land wie deutschland ich so von der
freiheit profitiert hat so vielen liebt
die freiheit dass die das nicht besser
einordnen können und parteien einfach
deutlich unterstützen was die grünen und
bernburg markt ist schon eine gute
schritt aber auch nicht der alleinige
wunsch der usa haben sie auch in dieser
woche gehört die taiwanische vertretung
in deutschland hat ja auch gefordert
dass hochrangige deutsche politiker nach
taiwan reisen sollten helly
empfehlenswert ja auf jeden fall also
ich meine frau berbalk schritt ist
definitiv ein wandel zur
vorgängerregierung aber das große
problem ist nach wie vor die spd also
die hat sich auch hin ganz aktuell
auffällig wenig positioniert und
natürlich stellt sich dann irgendwann
die frage oder nicht nur irgendwann
sondern ganz akut also die
wirtschaftlichen interessen in china
sind so gigantisch also die
abhängigkeiten sind auch so gigantisch
dass man sich schon im fall so ich bin
mir da nicht so sicher ob deutschland
wirklich so völlig auf thailand seite
stehen wird wenn es hart auf hart kommt
also und und das ist natürlich zutiefst
bedauerlich und ich halte das auch für
kurzsichtig aber hochrangige deutsche
politiker sollten reisen frau koelbl ich
erinnere noch mal an den titel lose sie
haben gerade den zeitpunkt angezweifelt
ob der so gut wäre jetzt gibt es ja den
plan der ist schon länger so der es
nicht an gekoppelt an die reise von
klose gewesen dass abgeordnete des
menschenrechtsausschusses im oktober
nach taiwan reisen sollen sie sind
natürlich nicht die hochrangigen über
die wir sprechen aber gute idee oder
sagen sie in der das feld für sie auch
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt ist eine
ausgezeichnete idee also in dieser level
ist auch überhaupt kein problem ich
denke es geht wirklich um die absprache
von hochrangigen vielleicht auch
staatspräsidenten oder premierminister
und das sollte dennoch eben in sprache
geschehen und zwar nicht weil ich der
meinung dass es nicht richtig wäre soll
ich bin der meinung dass es wirksamer
ist und auch beeindruckender ist und
damit auch kalkulierbarer ist also in
china muss wissen und da muss man
wirklich abfragen wie stabil ist diese
allianz aber ich glaube es braucht auch
eine weile bis sie sich findet china
muss wissen dass es reaktionen
zu erwarten hat und der preis sehr hoch
ist wenn es zum beispiel sich wirklich
irgendwann mal entschließen sollte noch
in der amtszeit von camping zum beispiel
anzugreifen werden wir über den hohen
preis der ist politisch und
wirtschaftlich viele menschen haben
angst auch vor einem krieg das muss man
auch mal klar so formulieren dass dann
der nächste die nächste front aber
dieses mal eben usa und china eben
aufbrechen und konkreter werden auf der
anderen seite muss man natürlich auch
sagen auch rein weltwirtschaftlich was
würde das überhaupt bedeuten wenn wir da
neue eskalationen erleben das würde ich
gerne auch noch mal so hier in dieser
runde rein geben was kann sich zum
beispiel deutschland da es überhaupt
leisten auch mit blick auf die
wirtschaft jetzt erstmal zum beispiel
also einerseits china deutschland sehr
abhängig wie inzwischen von der vom
chinesischen markt andererseits ist das
natürlich auch eine stärke deswegen
würde ich auch sagen ist deutschland
nicht nur irgendein akteur von vielen
und sollte sich auch nicht immer hinter
der eu verstecken sondern deutschland
ist der einer der zentralen akteure und
hat dann am ende natürlich auch einfluss
auf ihn also gerade aufgrund dieser
wirtschaftsstärke könnte konnte berlin
auch druck auf peking ausüben und
natürlich beeindruckt dass auch die
führung in peking wenn deutschland ernst
gemeinte sanktionen auch androht wenn es
zu einem worst case fall waren
realistisch bei dem was wir jetzt gerade
man muss das ganz realistisch darstellen
also damit es überhaupt nicht dazu kommt
muss man sanktionen ja glaubwürdig erst
mal androhen warum sind sie sich sicher
hätte ich aber so zum beispiel tina
schickt keine waffen an russland braucht
waffen die tine herrscht drohnen könnten
muss sehr gut herr seien aber beiden hat
china deutlich gemerkt das wird
konsequenzen geben sogar zu märkten eu
und usa wäre gefährdet wenn china wusste
unterstützen würde ergo keine
unterstützung von china aus ein paar
warme worte und das ist ganz gut die eu
und die usa haben gut zusammen mit
dieser drohung das ist für china
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen geben und
das ergebnis war wichtig wenn die eu usa
position auch mehr unterstützen würde
gegenüber taiwan dann würde china
vielleicht auch die single davon lassen
so viel drohgebärden gegen taiwan zu
machen müssen uns auch mal vor augen
führen ob da jetzt vielleicht in zukunft
neue linien oder alte linien die sehr
schon gibt noch mal deutlicher gezogen
werden müssen er sagt habe ich würde
bevor wir hier noch weiter in europa und
auch mit den usa unterwegs sind ihre
china brille wie sie es genannt haben
noch mal interessieren in china das auch
so war dass es mehr auf so eine
konfrontation usa china in nächster zeit
hinauslaufen wird ich glaube die sehen
sich mit drin in dieser konfrontation
das ist quasi das mantra was sowohl in
der propaganda nach also nach innen ins
land verbreitet wird aber auch was wir
was wir quasi in der im politischen
diskurs mit dem ausland sehen das ist
die usa sind quasi der stärkste
platzhirsch und china ist der
zweitstärkste und das ist die rolle die
sie sich nicht für länger habe
vorstellen können sondern das ziel muss
ein platz eins somit mit dieser
marschroute ist die regierung schießt
ihm unterwegs warum nicht weil es per se
darum geht der beste auf der welt zu
sein sondern weil es nur um eins geht
und das ist immer dasselbe in china die
kommunistische führung möchte auf ewig
ihren machterhalt zementieren wie kann
sie das in dem sie nach innen ein regime
der überwachung und kontrolle
festigt die bevölkerung im griff hat
zensiert jede form von von opposition
und zivilgesellschaft auf null drückt
und im ausland realisiert als ein
globaler
machthaber der von kaum mehr in frage
gestellt werden kann damit kann sich die
kp für die nächsten jahrzehnte fest
schreiben das ist das übergeordnete ziel
wie gefährlich ist das was da gerade an
verschiebungen stattfindet frage also
ich denke mal dass es wirklich
verschiebungen gibt dürfen aber nicht
vergessen
zum beispiel dass die deutschen
tatsächlich eine wichtige rolle spielen
die deutschen waren lange zeit der oder
sind vielleicht immer noch der
favorisierte partner von peking sowohl
was wirtschaftliche angeht als auch
offensichtlich der ansprechpartner in
der eu der hebel ist also nicht gering
tatsächlich ist es so dass die deutschen
immer sehr zurückhaltend sind man hat es
auch in der ukraine gesehen diese
abhängigkeiten sind da sie zu
diversifizieren wird eine ganze weile
dauern genauso wie die unabhängigkeit
vom gas herzustellen eben dauert wenn
man nicht einfach den gashahn zudrehen
möchte und seine bürger und seine
frieren und seine industrie stillstehen
lassen möchte ist auch hier die
diversifizierung eben ein prozess aber
es gibt eben auch diesen großen hebel
denn die deutschen haben ihr wort sie
sind nicht so aggressiv sie sind nicht
der direkte gegner für klima die
deutschen sollten beides machen sie
sollten wirklich ganz klar ihre
positionen darstellen sie sollten sich
für taiwan einsetzen sie sollten auch
mit absprache daneben mit den
amerikanern und anderen europäern vor
allen dingen
hochrangigen besucher dahin spielt aber
sie müssen auch china eine gewisse
flexibilität lassen darauf zu reagieren
weil sonst verhärten sich die fronten
zum beispiel es gibt ja nicht nur die
pink soll es gibt auch diese
nationalisten die da als
internet krieger unterwegs sind und
fordern dass morgen taiwan eingenommen
wird und aus dieser richtung kommt
jinping zum beispiel irgendwann mal
werden auch aktionen gefordert das ist
etwas womit die amerikanischen
präsidenten auch umzugehen haben das
volk will irgendwann mal auch action
sehen was ich bei ihnen auch auf höhere
das ist ja das was man auch in frage
stellen muss herr kirsch mal auf wie
möglicherweise die usa sich das
eigentlich für die zukunft vorstellen
dass man eigene wertesysteme eigene
politische systeme anders kombinieren
muss dass man nicht mehr sagen kann man
geht mit jedem auch wirtschaftliche
verbindung ein man muss vielleicht neue
ja einfach allianzen schmieden die man
bisher vielleicht noch nicht eingegangen
ist auch für die usa ja ich meine die
usa mit links und hat das vor 50 jahren
gemerkt mit china und usa ist ja
flexibel aber ist ganz wichtig zu
betonen manche denken die deutschen die
amerikaner wohnen im kriege führen eben
nicht die märkte wollen kriege
verhindern und amerikaner wollen zeigen
eine starke bereitschaft teilweise
verteidigen das ist nie so kriege kommt
und das ist wirklich das problem man hat
das hier in europa gesehen man hat
punkten belohnt mit quinn 2014 mit
scream 2 das war eine belohnung des
marktes leicht punkten gezeigt der in
zwei tagen kehrte vorbei es ist alles
jetzt so ein bisschen spät ukraine zu
unterstützen und americana wohnen auch
diese lehrer teilen gut vorbereiten gut
aufrüsten das ist nicht so einem krieg
kommt das ist das ziel und nicht ein
krieg zu führen sondern ein krieg zu
verhindern
und ich glaube auch dass es sinnvoll ist
sozusagen das preisschild was man jetzt
an teilbaren heftet so groß zu machen
dass sich die kp führung in peking ganz
genau überlegt kann ich mir das leisten
und wie der nochmals zurück sozusagen zu
der zu der eingangs formulierung die
kp-führung möchte die macht der
kommunistischen partei auf ewig
zementieren das heißt sie müssen immer
gucken zu welchem preis er kaufe ich das
und da glaube ich auch was felix wie am
anfang gesagt das team pink ist nicht
putin sondern die abwägung im apparat
von jean ping sind sozusagen auch mit
wirtschaftlichem kalkül und eben nur
wenn wir unsere bevölkerung in china
auch einen wachsenden wohlstand
versprechen werden wir von denen auch
weiter toleriert als staatsführung er es
gibt keine freien wahlen hat es ist das
sehr deutlich zum ausdruck was sie noch
mal sagen dass es eben sehr eng
zusammenhängt welche welches system
welches politische habe ich in meinem
eigenen land wie lässt sich das mit der
wirtschaft mit den wirtschaftsinteressen
weltweit verknüpfen deswegen vielleicht
der letzte gedanke für diese runde noch
hell die müssen wir uns vom thema
globalisierung wie wir sie in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten ja auch
versucht haben zu leben wieder
verabschieden und tatsächlich uns anders
aufstellen als deutschland als eu und
als welt also verabschieden sicherlich
nicht die globalisierung hat ja auch
viel gutes von viel wohlstand gebracht
und zwar nicht nur in europa sondern
weltweit aber wir haben schon
übertrieben und vor allem diese das
heißt man hat zu übertreten naja also
gerade die deutschen
oder ich trete auch in ungarn immer von
der gesamten deutschen wirtschaft weil
ich finde es sind jetzt auch nicht alle
unternehmen aber einige ganz spezifische
branchen also sprich die
automobilbranche oder der maschinenbau
die haben es so weit getrieben dass sie
inzwischen von den china geschäften
quasi erpressbar geworden sind und das
ist natürlich ein großes problem wenn
sich das dann auch in politisches
handeln dann widerspiegelt und das
erlebe ich derzeit sollen wie nehme ich
die spd gerade war und das ist natürlich
ein großes problem und insgesamt würde
ich sagen kann es nicht schaden wenn man
gewisse industrie doch auch wieder
zurückholt weil damit geht ja auch sehr
viel wissen verloren wenn man immer
alles nach china verlagert das begründet
der chinas aufstieg nämlich dass so viel
industrie nach china gegangen ist und
sie damit überhaupt so stark geworden
sind also vielleicht mit der
globalisierung etwas übertrieben ist die
letzte aussage die wir in dieser runde
so mitnehmen können wir kommen will zum
ende dieses presseclubs hier im ersten
geht es nämlich weiter mit dem
europamagazin unter anderem geht es
darum die hilfen der eu bei waldbränden
und sie kennen das schon auf phoenix und
wdr 5 sprechen wir gleich weiter zum
presseclub nachgefragt dann gerne auch
natürlich mit ihren fragen dankeschön
für ihr interesse dankeschön an die
runde ihnen noch einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]
ja und wir machen weiter hier mit dem
presseclub nachgefragt militär vor
taiwan peking lässt die muskeln spielen
das ist unser thema heute hier im
presseclub unsere gäste sind nach wie
vor da bereit gerne ihre fragen zu
beantworten und ich lege direkt mal los
mit klaus borchert aus hamburg hallo
herr borchert schon dass in unserer
runde sind
finde ich das ein bisschen gewagt das
auftreten von pierburg andererseits dazu
sagen wir wünschen keine gewalt wir
möchten das völkerrecht geächtet sehen
ist sehr respektabel aber ich sehe es
wenn man auch so verstehe ich das
jedenfalls dass taiwan doch
völkerrechtlich soweit ich das
beurteilen kann nach wie vor aktiv zu
china gehört also folgerichtig ist mal
wieder so gut wie von keinem anderen
land auf diesem planeten anerkannt und
da hätte ich gern einmal die meinungen
der runde keine dazu gehört zum status
von taiwan oder hongkong taiwan und so
gut wie gesagt das steht mal vom problem
bestehen ja helsa traviss was konnten
sie herr borchert darauf antwort ja
thailand hat natürlich dass etliche so
was wie ein völkerrechtlich schwer zu
butter in den stand insofern ist der ton
von frau bernburg nicht ganz zielführend
weil wir eigentlich ein schwebezustand
haben wir haben ein 1 1 eine
demokratische inselrepublik die aber von
vielen staaten den allermeisten staaten
der welt nicht anerkannt ist und
insofern sind wir hier also noch nicht
auf dem grund der tatsachen gelandet das
ist ein schwebezustand der
völkerrechtlich anders zu bewerten ist
als beispielsweise die ukraine ja meine
frage von herrn hübel aus ortenberg es
herr hubble wo ist das denn wo finden
wir sie
erhalten in hessen das passt ja auch
wunderbar er hätte sagen sie uns gerne
ihre frage ich glaube sie beschäftigen
sich ein bisschen mit der unabhängigkeit
chinas
gemacht durch die wirtschaftsbetriebe
warum man die usa und die eu
praktisch china bleibt den wir
die wirtschaftliche jungen runde
okay das ist jetzt hätte wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen drastisch formuliert
aber wir wissen in welche richtung sie
denken herr kirsch vom mögen sie
antworten ja ich habe herr lee hat das
auch in geantwortet in der runde dass
die usa die eu haben die chance china
ein bisschen zu bändigen wenn es
übertrieben übertreibungen kommt china
weist es auch deswegen bin ich
optimistisch ist wird nicht zum krieg
kommen ich bin optimistisch dass
vernünftige coole köpfe werden da die
werden muskeln zeigen ein paar raketen
ins meer schießen dass das ist gut für
das heimische publikum ein bisschen
applaus von der rechten in entschieden
die es brauchen aber gab die
wirtschaftliche hebel ist wirklich groß
und das weiß schiene und das heißt die
usa und das weiß hoffentlich deutschland
und die eu wenn dir das diese kreise
wänden wohnen
würde ich gerne noch hans-peter molter
mit reinholen in die sendung aus standen
wilhelm molterer gerne ihre fragen
sonntag und die damen und herren meine
frage mich warum jetzt das kroll die
große aufregung
es ist doch schon lange bekannt dass ein
start ziel wie die menschenrechte in
china sind wieso der mediale aufzug
es ist doch
geschäfte werden mit jedem anderen staat
gemacht der auch nicht demokratisch ist
und er hat keinen kopp leben eines saudi
arabien katar und und und die so wieder
auffrisst und was menschenrechte
behandlung möchte ich den herrn ihren
kollegen auf den usa
manchmal um herrn
also aus kümmern das war meine frage
okay das waren jetzt mehrere punkte
härter wird direkt das mal an herrn cash
war ein klarer auftrag an sie und wenn
sie sich immer was können sie darauf
antworten es ist ein sonderfall und
wunderbar
aber tatsächlich dazu sagen muss wir
reden ja heute hier im presseclub nicht
über herrn assange aber ich glaube der
andere teil war er durchaus auch für
unsere runde nicht unwichtig nämlich die
frage warum jetzt auf einmal diese
mediale aufmerksamkeit ja auch reli
wollte schon große unterschiede machen
also die menschenrechtsverletzungen die
in china stattfinden die übersteigen
natürlich bei weitem das was
man was teilweise aus den usa passiert
oder auch nicht passiert also deswegen
ich finde das ist schon nochmal andere
ganz andere dimensionen china die frage
auch zur warum die aufregung
das sind natürlich auch ganz andere
dimensionen inzwischen also a die
wirtschaftsstärke b aber auch wie china
sich verändert hat also ich würde ja mal
sagen auch wenn es immer noch beides
unter dem namen kommunistische führung
agiert allerdings der wechsel zu
schießen das kommt einem regime wechsel
gleich mit den leuten ich war 18 jahre
korrespondent in china mit den leuten
mit denen ich ihn anfangs denn zehn
jahre zu tun hatte auch auf
regierungsebene die sind komplett alle
weg jean ping hat mit seiner anti
korruptions kampagne hat über eine halbe
millionen menschen abgesetzt da in den
ganzen behörden bereichen also dass wir
reden von einem regime wechsel und das
spürt man ja auch also hieß dass china
von heute unterschiedlich ping ist noch
mal viel autoritärer nochmal die
menschenrechtsverletzungen haben
dimensionen angenommen die wo wir im
nachhinein als die nullerjahre als
liberale entspannte goldene jahre
empfinden also das sind alles gründe
warum die aufregung natürlich berechtigt
vorwürfe und frau körper eben erst dann
berlin hat jetzt die letzten zehn jahre
da geholt ich war da ich glaube vor zehn
elf jahren eine zeit lang in china und
da war eigentlich noch auf der kippe
wohin wird sich dieses land entwickelt
und man hatte durchaus die hoffen also
es war schon bedrückend damals aber man
hat ja auch wirklich sehr stark die
hoffnung dass sich das eventuell auf
weichen würde und genau das gegenteil
ist geschehen dass man das hat schleifen
lassen wie vielleicht auch in der
ukraine mit russland zum beispiel ist
sicherlich
auch deutschland vorzuwerfen
aber letztlich haben haben solche solche
fragen wie zum beispiel die
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegenüber die
uiguren das hat wirklich eine dimension
das übersteigt auch das was in saudi
arabien oder so stattfinde das ist
glaube ich ziemlich einmalig im moment
auf dem planeten und der sich 2009 2010
schon mal in peking war als reporter da
war china unter hu jintao und wen jiabao
mit sich selbst beschäftigt und mit der
frage wie können wir den wohlstand
mehren und wie können wir sozusagen den
menschen ein besseres leben bereiten als
sie den pink später ans ruder kam hat
sich ein ganz entscheidender
richtungswechsel ergeben nämlich der
blick viel ins ausland und seitdem ist
das ausland entscheidend im fokus der
kommunistischen führung da gibt es die
neue seidenstraße initiative die ruß
getreten wurde da ging es immer darum
auch verantwortung in internationalen
institutionen zu übernehmen und klammer
auf chinesische interessen dort zu
implementieren und zu festigen und immer
auch als system alternative für
demokratien seht her wir können schnell
wachsen können schneller autobahnbau und
können schnellen flughafen bauen können
schnell eine große bevölkerung versorgen
hier sind besser als ihr demokratien die
immer nur diskutiert man empfiehlt sich
und das sieht den ping international als
alternative das ist ein ganz anderer
schnack heute als noch vor zehn jahren
ich würde gerne unsere zuschauern und
zuschauer noch mal kurz mit reinholen
reinhard schneider aus ist oder auf
hallo herr schneider
guten tag in die runde
die
frau nicht kennt der weiß heute wer sie
ist ich habe den eindruck als wenn sie
nach vormonat gekommen wäre mit einer
fackel und die in einem munitionsdepot
gefahren werden um nachzusehen ob auch
wirklich noch befindet starke
bildsprache aus dem schneider wasser was
möchten sie uns fragen
ich möchte fragen
nach den wahren gefahren das heißt wir
das funktionieren gehe gleiche gewesen
und man hätte diese aufregung in der
chinesischen regierung nicht provoziert
mich wundert nur dass die chinesische
regierung doch deutlich unterscheidet
von der von dem land und von der
langfristigkeit ist ein kind durch
mögliche aussenpolitik ok herr schneider
vielen dank für ihre frage ich würde
jetzt mal mitnehmen in die runde
abgesehen von den starken bildern ist es
nicht sogar zu spät gewesen diese reise
stattfinden zu lassen möchte antworten
ja ich finde das eine berechtigte frage
also hätte vor zehn jahren wäre
wahrscheinlich auch eine andere
situation gewesen wahrscheinlich wäre
hätte auch viele das noch nicht so ganz
so aufgebauscht also ich glaube ja auch
dass das überhaupt ein starkes thema
jetzt geworden ist liegt ja auch nicht
zuletzt ein chinesischer seite wie wir
das auch diskutiert haben also china
selbst testen gerade aus wie weit china
gehen kann und möchte
also insofern
ist die ist die frage sicher berechtigt
aber
laut jüngsten rally noch an der stelle
sagen vielleicht herr kirsch war noch
dazu dass nancy pelosi das ist jetzt
nicht das erste mal dass sie sich für
taiwan entwickeln ihre ihre biografie
auch sie wissen wie sie sich in den
letzten jahrzehnten ja auch politischer
verhalten hat also ja sie ist seit zwei
jahren der sprecher des hauses deswegen
zeigt vor zehn jahren nicht mehr der
fall weiß ich nicht ja sie wollen ein
signal setzen und sie wurde sie wollte
tun bevor wir für mittelsachsens was sie
nicht mehr im amt ist und das war
wichtig für symbolpolitik in taiwan
pflanze flieger zu steigen und
wir haben nach den schwimmern aus
duisburg der noch eine frage stellen
möchte hallo herrsche man ja einen
schönen guten mit daran alle anderen die
republik
ja mir hat das gefallen was
verkehrsführung gesagt hat und die
vergleiche auch mit der ukraine was
wirtschaftlich china bedeutet ist jetzt
ziemlich deutlich auch gesagt worden man
muss das aber dynamisch sehen ich möchte
zur frage der ein china politik um
wir müssen davon wegkommen ist meiner
ansicht nicht wollte die kollegen danach
fragen wir haben nicht china einfach
stark gemacht jeder hat das recht sich
wirtschaftlich zu entwicklungen zu
expandieren aber china wie russland
versucht das mit militärischer gewalt zu
unterstützen um bedrohungen und auch
damit weltweit entsprechendes aufzubauen
1901 ich glaube ich hat man china taiwan
allein gelassen und damit haben wir eine
völlig andere zeit wir hatten den krieg
und china führt sie sich von russland
bedroht es waren ganz klar gegen st und
das passte dann damals dem westen
berechtigterweise mit china sich
anzunehmen und so weiß auch franz josef
strauß oder sieben zeit ist vorbei
und ich halte es für notwendig weg von
der ein-china-politik unseren schritt zu
schritt so der politik weil chinas sonst
können wir das nicht halten und wir
werden zum wohnort der chinesischen
ökonomie und des russischen militärs
dankeschön herstellern für ihre meinung
auch und ihre frage die eigentlich in
der politik müssen uns vielleicht auch
noch mal ganz kurz erklären und jeden
mitnehmen was ist die eigentliche
politik wirklich nur ganz kurz also ich
finde die frage wird im forderung total
berechtigt also die ein china politik
hat ein den ursprung dahingehend dass
nach dem verlorenen bürgerkrieg ja die
nationalisten nach taiwan ging und dann
letztendlich schon auch festlandchinesen
waren die auf teilt die quasi teilen
übernommen haben und gesagt haben die
können von taiwan aus china wieder
einnehmen so aber historisch gesehen war
teil war nie teil der volksrepublik das
muss man schon immer wieder betont und
ich würde da und ihnen auch recht geben
dem zuschauer dass es nicht mehr
zeitgemäß ist es gibt keine zweite
formel ein land zwei systeme was man
versucht hat auch auf hongkong
anzuwenden der gedanke unter den
shopping in den 80er jahren der dahinter
steckte war ja dass china damals
rückständig war hongkong sehr
fortschrittlich und man nicht hongkong
wenn man hong kong sich zurückholt
hongkong in den sog der armut gezogen
wird sondern umgekehrt deswegen gab man
50 jahre zeit in der hoffnung dass china
sich bis dahin auf aufgeholt hat und mit
hongkong gleichziehen kann und dann hat
man das wenig später auch von taiwan so
übernommen so aber jetzt ist ja ich den
ping missbraucht diesen
ursprungsgedanken jahren nutzt das ja
für seine machtpolitischen ambition und
will das aggressiv einvernehmen das war
überhaupt nicht der gedanke da der als
dass ein land zwei systeme wie das denn
der große reformer durch optimal
vorgegeben in der zwischenzeit haben wir
gesehen dass die das chinesische militär
weit vorgestoßen ist ins südchinesische
meer und auf atollen militärbasen hin
baut und damit reklamiert für sich dass
wir das dass china im südpazifik
sozusagen eine neue großmacht würde da
sind auch veränderte voraussetzungen die
wir in den vergangenen zehn jahren
gesehen ich würde gerne noch einen
zuschauer mit reinnehmen hans kopitz ist
das aus dem etat kassel hallo ihr
ja eine frage die auf jeden fall schon
reaktionen aus ja alles in ordnung gab
das haben wir verstanden eine durchaus
berechtigte frage die wir hier nochmal
mit in die runde nehmen die sich
natürlich vielen stellen frage sie haben
ja heute auch schon einiges zu diesem
thema gesagt müssen ja muss der westen
sich das vorschreiben lassen muss der
westen sich nicht vorschreiben dass
dabei muss man den reaktionen gegeben
also willkommen in der globalen
diplomatischen welt
letztlich ist es geht es in dieser welt
darum auch mit mit die reaktionen
richtig einzuschätzen sie richtig zu
kalkulieren und mit den folgen zu leben
wir sollten uns das leisten können wir
müssen uns das leisten können und darauf
müssen wir uns vorbereiten und ich
glaube darum geht es hier überhaupt aber
dabei muss man klug sein und nicht nur
hart vorgehen und nicht nur demonstrativ
vorgehen sondern vor allem
klug und mit bedacht und lang
langfristig denken und vorgehen hat er
schon wenn ich sie in dieser runde
richtig verstanden habe wünschen sie
sich dass er sogar noch mehr dass man
sich das gar nicht vorschreiben lässt
und einfach macht vor allem die usa
wünschen also auf jeden fall dass so ein
ding wenn wir sagen wir wollen besuchen
dürfte nicht und ich kann euch sagen die
amerikanerin lernen immer aus der
vergangenheit probieren die wichtige so
ziehen aus 38 mit münchen mit 20 14 mit
krim nicht das wieder passieren lassen
und gut vorbereitet sein für was kommen
könnte und ich bin überzeugt eine gute
verteidigungsstrategie vor taiwan wird
ein krieg verhindern nicht verursachen
sollte man sich das weiter vorschreiben
lassen vielleicht noch als schluss
antwort hier in dieser runde also so wie
frau koelbl dass der film formuliert hat
bin ich von ganz bei ihnen also klar man
muss konnte also vorschreiben auf jeden
fall nicht aber man muss mit dem die
sich die konsequenzen überlegen und
haben noch eine strategie entwickeln und
eine der strategien aber die muss dann
auch entwickelt werden und da ist jetzt
dringend zeit geboten also deutschland
soll es auch geben braucht eigentlich
braucht in der stadt szenarien wenn es
zum worst case kommt wie man darauf
entsprechend reagieren kann und muss
also das hoffe ich dass das jetzt in den
nächsten wochen auch geschieht die
hoffnung ist auf jeden fall da auch in
dieser runde hier das haben wir gespürt
und als auch nötig dass etwas da
verändert werden muss ich danke ihnen
für ihre fragen dass sie dabei waren
hier im presseclub nachgefragt das war
von uns danke nochmal in die wunde einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]